trop longtemps souvenez vous c'était en
2006 la france devait vaincre l'italie
pour devenir championne du monde de
football jusqu'à ce que zidane quitte la
partie sur un coup de tête au sens
propre comme au figuré
que s'était il alors passé tout le monde
avait tenté de lire sur les lèvres du
joueur italien materazzi pour décrypter
une éventuelle insultes et bien
l'intéressé vient enfin de livrer le
secret
christophe portera le mystère de la
chambre jaune reste entier celui du
carton rouge est levée
il a fallu un peu plus d'un an pour le
père c'est marco materazzi révèle
aujourd'hui dans un journal italien ce
qu'il a dit à zidane le soir du 9
juillet à berlin
je préfère ta [ __ ] de soeur aurait dit
le défenseur italien un zidane qui lui
proposait de lui échangé son maillot à
l'issue de la rencontre
le mot de trop pour zizou qui comme un
gamin fixe les limites pas d' insulte
pas la famille le coup de tête la finale
perdue la fin d'une carrière au fond
d'un vestiaire zidane le gentil la
personnalité préférée des français n'a
pas supporté que l'on s'en prenne aux
siens un an après zidane coule une
retraite dorée sans avoir pu accrocher
une deuxième étoile de champion du monde
à son maillot materrazi dit avoir
demandé pardon et affirme avoir mûri
dans quelques semaines il jouera contre
l'équipe de france un match qualificatif
pour l'euro 2008
tout sauf un match amical est en tout
cas sans savoir ce que materazzi avait
dit les français ont à nouveau voté pour
zidane en tête du classement de leur
personnalité préférée juste devant
yannick noah et nicolas hulot classement
à paraître demain dans le journal du
dimanche